[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Inn allen einen guten Abend
Franz Beckenbauer ist tot Katja das ist
ja ein Tag an dem höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht nur Fußball deutschland trauert ja
der Kaiser war beliebt so wurde er
genannt und wir haben gleich noch
Reaktion zum Tod der Fußballlegende ja
das also später wir beginnen unsere
Sendung auch mit einer Würdigung des
Mannes der den deutschen Fußball wohl
geprägt hat wie kein
anderer Trauer um Kaiser Franz
Fußballlegende Beckenbauer stirbt im
Alter von 78
Jahren bundesweite bauernproteste
tausende Landwirte kritisieren Sparpläne
der Bundesregierung und legen mit ihren
Traktoren zeitweise den Verkehr
lahm neue Partei gegründet das s
Wagenknecht hofft auf einen politischen
Neuanfang erstes Ziel die
Europawahl ja um kurz nach 17 Uhr kam
die Nachricht Franz Beckenbauer ist tot
der Mann den sie Respekt und
ehfurchtsvoll den Kaiser nannten weil
sein Fußballspiel von Eleganz und
Leichtigkeit sein Auftreten von Scham
und Weltläufigkeit geprägt war als einer
der ganz ganz wenigen gelang es ihm
sowohl als Spieler als auch als Trainer
Fußballweltmeister zu werden sein
Paradestück war die fußballwm nach
Deutschland zu holen ein Paradestück das
Jahre später an seinem glänzenden Image
kratzen sollte Ares Donzelli
erinnert
1974 der Moment des Triumphs Franz
Beckenbauer ist Fußballweltmeister der
leidwolf der Mannschaft 16 Jahre danach
ist der Teamchef der Nationalmannschaft
ein den Trainerschein hat er nicht geht
raus und spielt Fußball so hat er sie
ins Finale gegen Argentinien geschickt
bremes bringt den Titel und der Teamchef
sucht in Rom die Einsamkeit ja ich wurde
da von allen Seiten angequatscht und ich
wollte eigentlich meine Ruhe haben und
dann habe gedacht den einzigen die
einzige Platz wo frei war und wo ich
meine Ruhe hatte war auf dem Platz am 11
September 1945 in München geboren wächst
der in Giesing auf gegenüber ist ein
Bolzplatz Mutter Anthony erinnert sich
da haben da Latten weissen das
war
weniger Beckenbauer spielt von 1958 für
den FC Bayern macht in der
Jugendnationalmannschaft des DFB auf
sich aufmerksam ballsicher elegant ein
seltenes Zeitdokument als 15-Jähriger in
Lörch gegen die Schweiz und natürlich
trifft er
auch Trainerlegende cik Tschikowski
verpasst ihm bei den Bayern den letzten
Schliff sein Stern geht auf bei der
fußballwm 1966 in England Deutschland
wird zweiter und 1969 wird aus franz
als wir da in dem feyier waren war diese
Büste vom Kaiser Franz Josef den eren
und der sagt der Fotograf warchein war
langweilig sagt gestätig do neben diese
Büste hin und das habe ich gemacht und
das ist das Foto und von dem Tag an war
ich der kaiserfan sein jungenhafter
Scharm sorgt für TV Momente auch im
Sportstudio lebe ich mich dadurch ein
bisschen leichter dass ich das Leben
nicht zu ernst nehmen kennen sie das und
ist der Hang auch noch so steil ein
bisschen was geht all
weil
als Spieler holt er alle wichtigen
clubtitel Europapokalsieger Pokalsieger
allein fünfm Deutscher Meister 1994 wird
er sogar Präsident des FC Bayern
münchenh diese an Beckenbauers Kontakte
bringen die WM 2006 nach Deutschland
längst ist er nicht mehr nur Kaiser
sondern
Lichtgestalt 2014 dunkle Wolken ziehen
auf die FIFA sperrt die 90 Tage wegen
mangelnder Kooperation bei Fragen zu den
WM vergab gegen Russland und Qatar dann
ist vom gekauften Sommermärchen 2006 die
Rede von Steuerhinterziehung Franz
Beckenbauer wird schwer herzkrank Angst
vom Sterben hat er trotzdem nicht der
Tod ist das Leben ich ich glaube an ein
Weiterleben die Seele wird weiterleben
was so
Angst bei uns im Studio ist jetzt Markus
hm vom Sport Markus du hast Franz
Beckenbauers wirken sportlich aber auch
auf der Funktionärsebene journalistisch
lange begleitet was bedeutet der Tod von
Franz Beckenbauer man muss mit dem
Begriff Legende malmer sehr vorsichtig
sein aber Franz Beckenbauer glaube ich
war der die Legende des deutschen Sports
die Legende des deutschen Fußballs
Weltmeister als Spieler Weltmeister als
Trainer das sommermär hier nach
Deutschland geholt und dann gibt's diese
ikonischen Bilder von ihm 1970 bei der
WM mit der getbten Schulter er spielt
weiter weil das Auswechselkontingent
erschöpft wurde wurde und da sah man was
was der Franz bedeutet für den deutschen
Fußball und dann 1990 dieses Bild als
als Trainer in dem Abendhimmel von
romstat und all sein Leben reflektieren
lässt das sind so die Bilder die sich
eingeprägt haben und dann hat er eben
die WM noch nach Deutschland geholt und
damit glaube ich den dreifach tririumph
sozusagen aus Trainer Spieler und
Funktionär perfekt gemacht das wäre
jetzt meine zweite Frage es gab eben
nicht nur Licht sondern auch Schatten
und das hat eben mit der WM mit dem
sogenannten Sommer Märchen 2006 zu tun
genau aber man muss auch unter dem
Strich sagen ich glaube diese 6,7
Millionen die gezahlt wurden an
Schmiergeld waren glaube ich das
geringste jemals was man zahlen musste
für eine WM also kann man unterm Strich
sagen vielleicht die billigste WM
überhaupt denn Franz Beckenbauer musste
nach den Spielregeln der Fifa spielen
und die FIFA war zu derzeit hochgradig
korrupt die Weltmeisterschaften wurden
korrupt vergeben und es waren sehr sehr
viele korrupte Menschen innerhalb der
FIFA und mit diesen Leuten musste Franz
Beckenbauer sich aus auseinandersetzen
hat es gemacht hat die WM nach
Deutschland geholt und ich glaube das
Sommermärchen war das Märchen überhaupt
sportlich gesehen für Deutschland es hat
das Land vereint und Franz Beckenbauer
war der Architekt der Macher dieser WM
vielen Dank Markus haben für diese
einordnungs wird in den nächsten Tagen
natürlich noch viel zu lesen und viel zu
sehen geben auch der Kanzler hat Franz
Beckenbauer gewürdigt er sagte er war
für viele der Kaiser auch weil er über
Generationen für den deutschen Fußball
begeistert ja mehr Reaktion gibt's
gleich im Sport wir machen mit dem
nächsten Thema weiter es wurde ja laut
getrommelt entsprechend viele Landwirte
beteiligten sich zum auftagt ihrer
bundesweiten Protestwoche gegen die
Agrarpolitik der Bundesregierung da
waren 10tausende Bauern mit ihren
Traktoren im gesamten Bundesgebiet
unterwegs seit den frühen Morgenstunden
sperrten sie Autobahnauffahrten Tunnel
fairanleger und Brücken sorgten teils
für Kilometer lange Staus und jetzt
Tobias Hefner über Tag ein dieser
Proteste die wütenden auf Traktoren
vielfach genervte auf dem Weg zur Arbeit
im Berufsverkehr trafen Bauern und
Pendler schon früh am Morgen aufeinander
bundesweit in Traunstein am Alpenrand
genauso wie in
Hamburg Sternfahrten in die großen
Städte blockierte Straßen und versperrte
autobahnau Fahrten das ging vielen zu
weit ein bisschen Verständnis ist sicher
aber aber mer nicht weil ich will ja
irgendwo wieder hin wie hier in München
setzen die Bauern aber darauf dass nur
großer Lärm ihren Sorgen Aufmerksamkeit
verschafft der Vorwurf Bürokratie in
Zeiten der Ampel werde immer schlimmer
düngebedarfsermittlung Düngeverordnung
Wasserschutzgebiete wden ausgeweitet die
ganzen regeln was Tierhaltung betrifft
es WD uns über re gemischt wir sind
Fachkräfte wir wissen was wir tun wir
müssen nicht immer von außen koordiniert
werden konkret geht's derzeit um den
agrardesel Steuervorteile dafür sollen
stufenweise wegfallen die
Bundesregierung sieht keinen Spielraum
daran zu rütteln die Union hat geklagt
damit Geld gespart wird und die kzruher
richichter haben ihn recht gegeben die
Konsequenz ist das gespart werden muss
und jetzt versuchen wir die Last
möglichst gleich zu teilen sodass die
Bauern auch ein Stück weit die Last
tragen müssen sonst müssten andere mehr
Last tragen das wir aber auch nicht fair
die Bauern wollen dennoch erzwingen dass
die Regierung zurückrudert wie zuletzt
bei der Kfz-Steuer für
landwirtschaftliche Fahrzeuge wir sind
uns auch alle einig wenn nicht beide
Sachen zu 100% zurückgenommen werden
dann geht's weiter die ganze Woche
politischer Rückhalt für die Bauern
kommt aus einigen Bundesländern man hat
den Landwirten dieser Streichung vor den
Latz geknallt in einer Situation in der
wir Jahrzehnte von Strukturwandel hinter
uns haben
und dann tauchten wie hier in Dresden
mancher Orts noch protestierende auf die
die Bauernverbände eigentlich fernhalten
wollten rechte Gruppierungen mit ihren
radikalen
Parolen ja anders als ursprünglich
geplant wir haben das gerade gzehen
verzichtet die Bundesregierung auf die
Einführung einer kfzsteuer für Landwirte
und die Bezuschussung beim Agrardiesel
die wird auch nicht sofort wegfahren
sondern schrittweise und trotzdem ziehen
die Bauern die Protestwoche durch wie
nachvoll ist das wie gut oder schlecht
geht es den Landwirten wirklich
Christian Volk nähert sich dieser Frage
an die Landwirte in Deutschland erhalten
pro Jahr rund 6 Milliarden Euro
Subventionen von der EU das sind
mehrheitlich sogenannte Flächenprämien
bedeutet mehr Fläche mehr Geld und
umgekehrt aber einen Teil erhält der
Landwirt nur wenn er bestimmte
ökoregelungen erfüllt und die
paachtpreise für Land sind stark
angestiegen vom Bund gibt es bisher
zusätzlich 2,4 Milli EUR pro Jahr zwei
der größten Posten die kfzsteuer und der
Agrardiesel bei dem gekürzt werden soll
wir wissen auch dass diese
dieselbeihihilfen kleinere Betriebe
wahrscheinlich sehr sehr hart treffen
weil die haben eben nicht so ein großen
Gewinn die sind auch nicht so optimal
motorisiert wie die sehr groß ein großer
Betrieb würde genau kalkulieren wie viel
brauche ich für dem Hektar bei kleineren
Betrieben kann man das in der Form gar
nicht machen zuletzt konnten die die
Bauern einen Rekordgewinn einfahren
durchschnittlich etwa
115 000 € pro Betrieb im Vergleich zu
den Vorjahren geht es vielen Landwirten
wirtschaftlich gerade also besser mehr
als 40% des Gewinns machen allerdings
auch die Subventionen aus die großen
Unternehmen erhalten wesentlich mehr
Subventionen als die kleineren
Unternehmen die kleineren Unternehmen
sind aber zahlenmäßig deutlich mehr
ungefähr die Hälfte aller Betriebe in
Deutschland sind Nebenerwerbsbetriebe
groß gegen klein die Spanne geht immer
weiter auseinander seit Jahrzehnten
nimmt die Zahl der Betriebe ab weil
kleine Höfe keine Existenzgrundlage mehr
haben und die großen immer größer werden
müssen und zu den Protesten der
Landwirte gibt es ein ZDF Spezial gleich
im Anschluss an unsere Nachrichten ja
auch wenn sich viele Ministerpräsidenten
mit den Landwirten solidarisierten das
Bundeskabinett hat heute die Kürzungen
beim Agrardiesel abschiedet sie gehören
zu einem Sparpaket für den
Bundeshaushalt
2024 ab Mai soll es auch eine höhere
Ticketsteuer für Flugreisen geben
außerdem sind Verschärfungen beim
Bürgergeld vorgesehen Ende Januar soll
der et für dieses Jahr dann vom
Bundestag beschlossen
werden es sei ein bisschen auch ein
historischer Tag sagt Sarah Wagenknecht
heute morgen haben sie und ihre
Mitstreiter also offiziell ihre Partei
gegründet vi und 40 Gründungsmitglieder
stehen hinter dem Bündnis Sara
Wagenknecht darunter Berufspolitiker
aber auch Quereinsteiger zu den Finanzen
da geht die Partei mit einem
Startkapital von 1,4 Millionen Euro ins
Rennen dank Spenden die erste
bewwhährungsprobe wird dann die
Europawahl im Juni sein Christiane
hübscher der eigentliche Moment Sarah
Wagenknecht unterzeichnet die
Gründungsurkunde ihrer Partei ein neues
Bündnis das weder links noch rechts sein
gegen mehr Migration gegen Gendern gegen
das verbrennerverbot aber für
solidarische Wirtschafts und
Sozialpolitik stehe weil die Menschen
ihre Brot und Butter Themen die Themen
die ihr ganz alltägliches Leben
ausmachen dass sie gut bezahlt werden
dass ihre Arbeitsplätze sicher sind dass
sie aber auch nicht Angst haben müssen
im Alter arm zu sein dass sie in
Wohnungen leben deren mieten Sie
bezahlen können mit der früheren linken
Fraktionschefin Amira Mohammed Ali
bildet Wagenknecht die Parteispitze auf
im Podium eine weitere Überraschung der
frühere Oberbürgermeister von Düsseldorf
ich war 40 Jahre lang Mitglied der SPD
heute habe ich mich dem Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit
angeschlossen auch der exlinken
Finanzpolitiker die Masi gehört nun zu
Wagenknecht gemeinsam mit Geisel stellt
er das Spitzenteam für die Europawahl im
Juni erste Bewährungsprobe für das neue
Bündnis weniger ist mehr ich möchte ein
Europa das sein Job macht und sich auf
die Dinge konzentriert wo es ein
unterched für die Menschen machen kann
dies betrifft etwa die minimumb
Besteuerung internationaler Konzerne die
verbliebene linke kämpft auch mit der
Lücke die wagenknechtsteam hinterlässt
bei der einen oder anderen
Persönlichkeit schmerzt mich das
natürlich dass die der Linken den Rücken
gekehrt haben aber letztendlich ist
meine Partei stabil bis tief in die
kommun hinein dass sie die einzige mit
ostbiografie im Vorstand ist nennt Sarah
Wagenknecht heute selbst einen
Schönheitsfehler fähiges Personal für
die drei be Landtagswahlen im Osten wird
hinter den Kulissen dringend
gesucht die massiven russischen
Luftangriffe auf ukrainische Städte
gingen auch heute weiter nicht alle
Raketen konnten abgefangen werden
mindestens vier Zivilisten kamen ums
Leben im Osten im Raum hakif konnten
Menschen aus den Trümmern eines Hauses
gerettet werden Luftalarm gab es im
gesamten Land in der Hauptstadt Kiev
suchten viele in U-Bahnstationen
Schutz in Frankreich ist ist die
Regierung von Premierministerin born
zurückgetreten hintergrund ist offenbar
das jüngst verabschiedete
migrationsgesetz das schlüsselvorhaben
von Präsident macron ging nur mit großen
Schwierigkeiten durch das Parlament wann
eine neue Regierung steht und wer sie
anführen wird ist noch
unklar eigentlich hatte die
Bundesregierung entschieden keine
Eurofighter Kampfjets an Saudi Arabien
zu liefern auch wegen der
Menschenrechtslage dort jetzt eine
kertwende Berlin ist offen für die
Exporte Außenministerin berbock betonte
der Golfstaat fange Raketen ab die hui
Rebellen aus dem Jemen auf Israel
abfeuern damit trage Saudi-Arabien zur
Sicherheit Israels bei und Dämme die
Gefahr eines flächenbrands in der Region
ein bei ihrem Besuch in narost
unterstrich Außenministerin bbock erneut
die Forderung nach einer zweist
staatenlösung im Westjordanland forderte
sie Israel auf die palästinensische
Bevölkerung besser vor Übergriffen
extremistischer Siedler zu schützen der
Siedlungsbau sei illegal und untergrabe
den dauerhaften Frieden so bbock in
ramalla traf sie ihren palästinensischen
Amtskollegen Riyad
almaki mit einer industriepolitischen
Ansiedlung will Deutschland mehrere
Fliegen mit einer Klappe schlagen
batterieproduktionen für E-Autos dort wo
grüne Windenergie entsteht bei Heide in
Schleswig-Holstein 3000 Arbeitsplätze
für eine strukturschwache Region ab
2029 mindestens 800.000 Batterien heute
nun das ok der EU Wettbewerbshüter mit
902 Millionen Euro darf Deutschland die
Ansiedlung der schwedischen Firma northw
fördern Henna
Hebestreit in Schweden produziert northw
Batterien für die Elektromobilität auch
deutsche Autobauer sind daran beteiligt
jetzt ist northw einen großen Schritt
weiter gekommen auch in Deutschlands
Norden eine Fabrik mit 3000 Jobs
Ben die EU-Kommission hat zugestimmt
dass Subventionen für northw in Höhe von
gut 900 Millionen Euro den
Wettbewerbsregeln
entsprechen damit ist es der EU gelungen
für den Zukunftsmarkt der
Elektromobilität eine wichtige Weiche zu
stellen für Europa und das war auch die
Begründung für diese Genehmigung heißt
es dass wir eine mögliche
Schlüsselindustrie bei uns behalten die
Firma hatte ja mit Abwanderung äh
gedroht Bundes und Landesregierung
hatten intensiv für den Standort in der
Region Heide in Schleswig-Holstein
gekämpft es ist ein wichtiger
Etappensieg diese Firma hat in ganz
Europa Standorte gesucht sie haben sich
für diesen Standort entschieden weil
erneuerbare Energien dort reichhaltig
zur Verfügung stehen das zeigt dass
Klimaschutz auch ein ökonomischer
Vorteil ist rund um Heide laufen
Vorbereitungen für den Bau der Fabrik
das letzte Wort haben die betroffenen
Gemeinden vor Ort für uns in
Schleswigholstein eine besonders gute
Nachricht denn das ist jetzt die
Grundlage dafür dass die Beschlüsse in
den Gemeinden auch zur baulleitplanung
getroffen werden können diese
Entscheidung ob das Werk für rund 4,5
Milliarden Euro tatsächlich gebaut
werden kann wird Ende des Monats
erwartet so wir sind jetzt beim Sport
und bei Katja streso und noch mal zum
Tod von Franz beckenbau Katja ja und die
Sportwelt sie trauert DFB Präsident
Bernt neundendorf würdigt ihn als einen
der besten den der Sport je gesehen hat
aus England kontuliert Fußballstar Gary
lincker und auch die Münchner Gedenken
des
Kaisers großes Idol als Fußballer ja
habe früher selber gespielt und ich fand
die Art wie er gespielt hat immer super
später hat er viel verspielt aber
insgesamt war doch wohl ne ein wichtiger
Repräsentant des deutschen fball
Fußballs ich muss auch sagen es ist
schade vor allen Dingen schade wier zum
Schluss behandelt wurde also dass er so
dann halt böse dann hingestellt wurde
wegen der wmvorgabe das er hat ja viel
für das klingt so blöd aber viel für
Deutschland getan für den deutschen
Fußball und man sollte das
Respektieren jetzt zum Handball da
beginnt übermorgen die
Europameisterschaft Gastgeber
Deutschland empfängt die Schweiz live im
ZDF und vor einer Rekordkulisse mehr als
50.000 Fans werden in Düsseldorf
erwartet wenn Handball im Fußballstadion
gespielt
wird seit einer Woche laufen die
Arbeiten in der nordreheinwestfälischen
Landeshauptstadt damit das
Fußballstadion zu einer handballarena
wird doch die Rekordkulisse bringt do
einige Umstellungen sei vielleicht ein
etwas längerer Weg von der Kabine sei
ein anderes Bild hinter den Toren das
ist immer bisschen ungewohnt wenn da
sehr viel Tiefe dahinter ist darauf
haben wir die Mannschaft aber einem
Termin vorbereitet am Abend findet das
erste Training in der Arena statt davor
gab es für die Spieler nur Tipps von
außen ich konnte DAV mit meinem
Vereinstrainer sprechen der selbst meem
Fußballstadion gespielt hat konnte mir
da so ein bisschen was zu erzählen dass
schon ein bisschen andere Atmosphäre ist
als in der normalen Handballhalle freuen
können sich Spieler und Zuschauer auf
jeden Fall auf eine spektakuläre
Stimmung Anwurf für das erste deutsche
Spiel gegen die Schweiz am Mittwoch um
20:45 Uhr live im
ZDF und schon davor gibt's eine
sehenswerte duku zum Weg der Handballer
auf ja auf dem Weg zur EM dann vielen
Dank Katja morgen das kann ich ih jetzt
schon mal sagen knackig kalt und oft
sonnig dazu mehr von öst and terle beim
Wetter das heute journal um
21:55 Uhr mit Marietta Slomka wir sagen
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen gleich geht
es weiter mit dem ZDF Spezial zu den
bauernprotesten und direkt danach gibt
es ein ausführliches Portrait von Franz
Beckenbauer schönen Dank und schönen
[Musik]
Abend
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja die Tiefs
müssen sich derzeit andere Bahn suchen
z.B hier über dem Mittelmeer die
allmählich ostwärts ziehen bei uns
herrscht nämlich hoher Luftdruck und da
haben die tiefst erst einmal keine
Chance aber in der Nacht kühlt es
ordentlich aus denn es gibt nur wenige
Wolken oft funkeln die Sterne einzig
Richtung Schleswigholstein ist es mal
dichter durch Nebel die Temperaturen im
strengen Frostbereich bis -15° hier im
Osten generell in der osthäfte
zweistellige Minuswerte ganz im Westen
dagegen einstellig am mildesten noch
oder am wenigsten frostig Richtung
Nordsee z.B bei
-3°. ja und morgen dann viel
Sonnenschein und ein unangenehmiger
böhiger Ostwind ja und dann fühlt sich
das ganze noch kälter an die
Temperaturen erreichen -6° als
Höchstwerte hier z.B im Osten 0° ganz im
Westen und ein°ad z.B Richtung Nordsee
ja sonnig geht's weiter in den nächsten
Tagen aber auch eisig -3 bis 2° am
Mittwoch leichte frostabschwächung dann
Richtung Freitag und etwas Regen im
Norden damit einen schönen Abend